hello everyone thank you for coming to
the NCBI webinar on the evolution of
NCBI style hackathons Peter Cooper the
head of the communications group is here
with me to answer specific questions and
I will answer more general questions at
the end of the webinar answers that we
don't get to will be available link to
our webinars page and also the materials
will be available on our FTP site
alright let's go ahead and get started
so at this point we've run about 13 NCBI
Style hackathons over the course of this
webinar to tell you about what NCBI
hackathons are what we do in these NCBI
style hackathons and how you can get
involved so what we do at NCBI style
hackathons in short is we put together
teams of 5 to 6 individuals who all work
on different bioinformatics projects in
a collaborative way and 80% of those
teams finish a functional software
prototype at the end of three days these
aren't 3 24 hour days in fact they're
typically three nine-hour days those
nine hours are really filled with very
focused work when we started these
hackathons we were teaching a lot of
workshops in next-generation sequencing
and we thought hackathons would be a
good way to offer very advanced next
generation sequencing courses what we
quickly realized is that what we were
actually doing was rapidly building
software prototypes and that was the
major motivation for people coming to
these hackathons so what we ended up
doing was really optimizing the
hackathons such that the teams develop
software prototypes and like I said
earlier about 80% of teams in the NCBI
hackathons develop working software
prototypes so in our first Agathon we
built for functional software products
including things like variant calling
for RNA seek that was that was pretty
neat and really did a survey of
available tools for
calling variance in our day see those
tools have really progressed a lot but
it was nice to have a place where you
could really see things in one place in
August 2015
we built six functional software
products and a couple of them including
the sort of machine learning based
pharmacogenomics prediction pipeline are
still in active development in fact the
Agathon's in total we've developed about
80 software products and about 40 of
them are stable or still in active
development this is a picture this is a
subset of the people that were in that
particular hackathon and this is
approximately what at NCBI hackathon
looks like although as I'll discuss
later now they're in many many different
locations all of the tools that we build
in NCBI hackathons are totally
open-source and we put everything on
github as I'll talk about later we also
containerize things so we we also see
manifestations on docker hub Jupiter
other places as well we build several
things in NCBI hackathons and things end
up in several places some things end up
being worked into NCBI production I'd
say that's sort of a minority of things
other things end up being part of our
standalone bioinformatics tools but
other things really end up being part of
educational experiences and we work them
in two webinars but also in two larger
scale online genomics courses and one
thing I'm particularly proud of
we built an educational resource for RNA
seek which is self-guided and you can go
to right now and fire up some cloud
instances either on Google Cloud engine
or Amazon Web Services and teach
yourself how to do RNA seek mapping with
star high set and magic blasts like I
said we worked this into an online
workshop the first five lectures of that
online workshop are available on YouTube
right now 2016 we really sort of
extended the frequency these hackathons
became very
popular and we started having them in
other places including Cold Spring
Harbor is a B and also hack seek was an
NCBI style hagath on that was run in
Vancouver and I was a participant not an
organizer of that event and it was a
very special very large NCBI style
hackathon so then in January we went
back to our main product or sort of the
regular hackathon rotation and we really
started building things that integrated
with larger software pipelines including
things like SRA 2r which you can see
here in the middle of your screen which
is an R package and we'll probably end
up in bioconductor
as a way to port data from SRA into our
frameworks we also started partnering
with other groups and I mentioned hack
seek before we were able to also start
building novel things like for example
ways to compare structural variants to
structural variant databases and that's
that's really been a neat focus of some
of our work is working with structural
variants as there are in my opinion not
enough tools to analyze that kind of
data in the bioinformatics community
like I said we started working with bio
Khanda a little bit with linux Peru as
well as bioconductor a lot of the things
in our hackathons deal well with the
sequence read archive like the SRA to
our package I mentioned earlier we're
also interested in fostering community
involvement with these hackathons it'll
talk about that even more at the end but
we were able to build a platform for
metadata categorization by NLM indexers
so they were able to go ahead and
annotate metadata in geo which has been
a bio informatics community hobby for
the last 15 or 20 years and we were they
actually annotated all of the metadata
for 14,000 drosophila RNA seek data sets
which we then used in a collaboration
with flybase we've also been able to
harmonize some of the metadata in in DB
gap with the nih come
repository another thing that I'm
particularly excited about is the
ability to do really experimental things
so to our knowledge until this point was
very very difficult for people to put
full genomes into a graph and few people
had attempted it and so in a hackathon
we ran in Cold Spring Harbor we were
able to load seven full human genomes
into AVG base graph structure and that
was something that I think was quite
neat and a project that's ongoing we've
also been able to work quite a bit on
immuno genic peptides looking at
classifying different types of immuno
genic peptides from cancer bacteria as
well as viruses and this is something
that I think is a particular clinical
relevance it's called danger track this
is effectively as a public blacklist for
regions of the human genome that are
relatively unstable and hence really
unsuitable for algorithmic short variant
calling so basically this tells you
where as a clinician you might want to
do double check before you report
particular variants to a patient so I
have a question from the audience asking
if these hackathons are focused solely
on genomics so it's a very good question
the hackathons are mostly genomics based
but we have done some non genomics
projects particularly in external
hackathons we in fact we had one product
project that was working with EEG
technology that said the majority of
them are based around genomics but with
the big caveat that in January each
January we have a sort of biomedical
informatics hackathon at the National
Library of Medicine and that really gets
into a lot of things you know involving
text mining and so on so thank you for
that question
so in 2017 we've really sort of evolved
to emphasize containerization
publication and accessibility of these
hackathon products and and I'm really
sort of proud of this because I think
one of the things that the hackathons
really contribute to the community is
speeding up science and I told you
before that at the
point about 80% of the hackathon
products become functional prototypes
but another thing I'm particularly proud
of is about 10% of them get published as
manuscripts often within a couple of
months of finishing the project in the
hackathon and that's that to me is is
really quite neat
I think accelerating scientific
publication in my personal opinion is is
very important one of the things that's
very accessible that we built in a
hackathon is fan var and you can see the
URL here it's fan mark colorado edu this
will generate word clouds of concepts
koh mentioned with snips in PubMed
abstracts but my friends liked to remind
me that word clouds really aren't
serious science but what is serious
science is this will also generate d3
rendered networks of snips and
particular p.m. IDs so that may be
useful to some of the folks in the
audience and to the question before this
is an example of some of the sort of
biomedical text mining stuff we do and
integrating with genomics something
that's sort of pure text mining we built
something called pub runner I'm very
excited about pub runner basically what
it is is a framework for natural
language processing tools that
continuously updates the PubMed corpus
and this this framework could also be
used to update other corpora for natural
language processing research and we're
working on packaging this and
collaborating with a lot of groups to to
allow them to auto update their PubMed
corpus if you're interested in this
please send me an email it's been B and
dot B USB Y at nih gov the head
developer of this in a hackathon jay
cleaver is currently working in my group
for the next four weeks on this project
so this would be a particularly good
time to contact me we've also been able
to take other people's software products
and really put them in more reproducible
frameworks so we have a common workflow
language pipeline for epigenomics called
screw and if you do epigenomics I'd
really encourage you to check that out
because I think that reproducibility
is really important but particularly in
the epigenomic space and we've been able
to collaborate in this particular case
with ga4gh so this is actually a slide
generated by the Global Alliance data
working group and it shows NCBI is a
repository that will work with their API
but at the time they made this slide
ncbi's data repositories actually didn't
work with their reads API but in a
hackathon we were able to stitch these
two things together and it really worked
quite beautifully and and right now
we're working actually to extend this to
be able to work with raw data on the fly
so basically the idea is that the reads
API can even work on unaligned data so
that's something I'm particularly
excited about as we go to more and more
sort of decentralized databases for this
type of genomic data in in other things
we've also done things like looking at
resources for for RNA seek both viewing
and doing counts as well as
identification of novel viruses that's
something I'm particularly excited about
but also when we announce teams that
that want to work on virus
identification and integration they are
extremely popular at the hackathons so I
think that's it's a topic that really
grabs the imagination and enthusiasm of
folks that attend our hackathons
speaking of I'd like to take a brief
segue and talk about the kind of people
that come to our hackathons so typically
they're computational biologists who are
either sort of senior graduate students
or postdocs and people that lead the
teams that the hackathons are typically
sort of senior postdocs or people at the
assistant professor level that said
there are exceptions to every rule and
we've had fairly young people both
attend and even lead teams at the
hackathons so if you're interested
please contact me directly or simply
sign up for a hackathon we've also been
able to foster community involvement
with the hackathons project in a couple
of other ways we're starting to build
educational resources that
really help people leverage community
tools then I'm going to talk about an
expansion of this a little bit later so
this is the e direct cookbook which will
probably be mentioned in next week's
NCBI webinars on API but I'll show you
that these are Jupiter notebooks that
we're building to enhance NCBI education
and we really hope to build a whole
suite of computational resources that
are used to leverage ncbi databases and
we think that's going to be really
helpful to the community and if you're
interested in getting involved in those
projects whether it's through hackathons
or through some other means please feel
free to contact myself or Peter Guber
next I want to show you some really
cutting-edge stuff that we built just a
couple of weeks ago and these are think
projects that I'm very excited about in
them I'm really proud to say that
they're still fairly stable and in
ongoing development one of the things we
built is a very simple easy to use tool
for looking at antimicrobial resistance
genes in metagenomics datasets um this
really heavily leverages magic blast
which is a new flavor of blast optimized
to deal with next generation sequencing
reads that we built at ncbi and also use
the card database to identify some of
these meta genomic resistance genes
although I think it's very attractive to
integrate databases as well as putting
in some learning modules so I really
encourage you to go to github grab this
code check it out it's docker honest
it's very easy to leverage and use on
anybody's Linux system and right now the
cancer genomics cloud is free and you
can also leverage it there so that may
be something to check out we're also
really interested in streaming data and
and what this particular thing does so
we we built a database of adapters that
are present in the SRA the really neat
thing about that is if you know what the
adapters are in SRA for your particular
data set then you can trim the adapters
on the fly so if you want to
if you want to do some assembly and
generate context now you actually don't
have to do fast queue dump anymore
you can simply trim your adapters on the
fly and then go ahead and build contacts
from streaming data which is something
that I think is very attractive the NCBI
infrastructure but with just also with
genomic data getting larger and if you
have any general questions on that I'd
love to answer them on FTP or once again
you can email me directly I was
particularly proud of a team they came
from a particular academic institution
and they really wanted to build a viewer
for an excellent Mouse aging data set
and what they actually ended up doing
was building really modular types of
viewers for existing RNA seek viewers
and I think that's really important
because there are currently 35 RNA seek
viewers that are up in the community and
supported about thirty-five and I think
it's really important to say well if you
have a particular thing that you want to
be able to view it's it's great to build
modular tools that you can insert into
those viewers and that's something we've
become really really interested in and
at the end of the hackathon we were able
to generate movies looking at Mouse
aging with and without infection to flu
and what's really amazing to me is even
at this extremely zoomed out level of
the mouse genome you're able to see
responses to influenza over long periods
of time there is a question about
virtual hackathons but I will wait till
the end to get into that and this was a
really experimental project and and I
think I look forward to iterate on this
project I'm really to be frank this team
was filled with brilliant people but I'm
not sure that random flipping is the
most prudent obfuscation model but but
basically what this does is it sends a
robot into anybody's data sets looks for
particular variants and that if it's
desired by the people that own the data
it off you skates the data so it's no
longer personally identifiable the nice
thing is that switch can be flipped back
off to generate a full data
matrix if some collaboration agreement
is reached base and which is obviously
consistent with the contagion consents
on the data we've also been helping out
with other people's hackathons that's
something I'm particularly proud of
we've helped out with some things at by
OIT as well as recently an artificial
intelligence genomics hackathon in San
Francisco and these are things we look
forward really look forward to to
working with also on the NCBI hackathons
github site which I'll put up in the
last slide you can find repo for being
able to run your own NCBI style
hackathons which I'd be happy to help
out with as well but if you just want to
roll your own please please feel free to
take any pieces of this and do that I
think we'd like to see more of this and
there's there's certainly no shortage of
folks that are interested in also our
next hackathon is in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania at the end of September and
one of the things we're likely going to
be working on is it out of the box a
sort of automatic hackathon builder and
that's that's something I'm pretty
excited about so I mentioned that there
are publications out of the hackathons
in one of the places we published these
hackathon results as well as allow other
people to publish these hackathon
results is in f1000 research and and
they've been really sort of wonderful in
in working with us on publishing
hackathon tools but certainly some
communication of these tools has gone to
other journals as well you can also
follow at DC genomics on Twitter so and
in other places on Twitter we try to
advertise things in these hackathons
this is a picture of some of the folks
in the New York gene of the most recent
New York genome Center hackathon in June
and that was really a fantastic
experience a lot of folks from both that
metro area as well as folks that came in
from across the country and even other
countries so like I said here's a list
of some of the upcoming hackathons if
any of you are in California there will
almost certainly be a northern Cal
for Nia hackathon the first week in
April likely either at UCSC or UCSF and
we're trying to work on a Southern
California hackathon that may occur in
January so please check this site for
that finally the actual repos can be
found both at this this github
organization and then sort of stable and
other other projects that are continuing
to be developed can be found at this URL
NCBI hackathon C github do so thank you
very much for your time via blog post
coming out on NCBI insights about some
of the products from the last three
hackathons Boulder Colorado New York
genome Center as well as the one we just
ranted in CBI and now I'm going to take
questions and I actually have one queued
up here and and it's an excellent
question so the question is are there
plans to host virtual hackathons so
we've done quite a few experiments with
virtual hackathons and one thing we've
seen is that we would we involve virtual
people we actually see not even sort of
less production but dramatically less
production from the people that are
involved online at least that's been our
experience so far however the last
experiment we did on that we had a
hackathon veteran somebody who had been
to several hackathons working part time
to sort of work on modular tools and
that was a very positive experience
we've also had people do quite a bit of
work online after the hackathons so so
what I could see a model of is sort of
hackathon veterans or people coming to
in-person hackathons of this style and
then continuing to work independently
that said of course there are other
hackathon models that work very well
online sort of long term competitive
hackathons tend to work very well online
and one of the things we've talked about
doing is in the virus discovery space
as well as the antimicrobial resistance
space is hosting sort of long-term
online hackathons to really leverage
some of the tools we've built in the
in-person hackathons and use them to
analyze data sets I would also like to
mention that there will be a second year
of hack seek so that's the big awesome
genomics hackathon in Vancouver I
mentioned and you can actually go there
and register at hack sitcom so a neat
thing is that there are now other
hackathons running on this model someone
else asked does the hackathon have a
slack channel or team and in fact this
is a great question so each hackathon
has its own slack organization which
obviously persists after the hackathons
we originally ran them through Google
Groups
and then we moved to slack and that's
been very popular we also have a
LinkedIn group for a hackathon alumni
where jobs are posted people can talk
about issues that sort of thing and we
also make announcements and that's
something I'm really proud of because
what I think we're doing with the NCBI
hackathons and other NCBI style
hackathons like hack see is we're
creating a community of really both
excellent computational biologists but I
think we're also seeing evidence
suggests that suggests that these people
work well with other people
and and really in my experience are
really kind of nice people and so I
think this actually also makes an
excellent tool for building a phenomenal
computational biology work force that
alumni group may actually expand from
being mostly a LinkedIn presence to
slack and other avenues of social media
I'd also like to mention that in the
third week of June 2018 we're having a
hackathon in Boulder Colorado as part of
a genomics conference and we'd really
like that to be mostly what we're
calling a champions hackathon so mostly
hackathon alumni
that come to Boulder and really work to
integrate some of the projects and build
sort of larger scale bioinformatics
platforms so like I said bringing those
people back and and having them continue
to work for the bioinformatics community
finally we're starting to integrate with
other bioinformatics hackathons that you
may be familiar with so I've been to the
bosk Agathon's and we're talking with
them about integrating as well as sort
of the general bio hackathons community
and elixir those are things I look
forward to telling you about sometime
soon great well thank you for the really
great questions people that ask
questions I think with that and actually
typically many times I don't put the Q&A
session on the recording but I think
perhaps for this one will be popular so
thanks to everybody who attended and all
you hack a thon alumni out there there's
a couple in attendance here and with
that I think we'll go ahead and sign off
if you have any further questions please
feel free to email me and we just have
we have one or two spots available for
the Pittsburgh hackathon the deadline is
closed but if you're very very
interested and you're able to go to
Pittsburgh September 25th 26th and 27th
please go ahead and sign up thank you
very much everybody and have a fantastic
rest of the day have a fantastic week
and tune in next week for an NCBI
webinar on NCBI api's I think you'll
find that there's a lot more NCBI api's
than you thought there were
you